of course you have to work hard but it's
a lot of it's a lot about
you need to be in the right place in the
right time and
there is a huge element of of luck in
this
road
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders thank you very much for
hosting me
first things first there's a jungle
behind you talk to me about this jungle
okay so um even before the corona
you know we had the i'm i think that
you know we're not living in a
sustainable
and i have look i've been looking for
ways to
grow my own stuff in my backyard to have
a local
basically almost almost being like an
attack
a market so grow my stuff
okay and i've been vegan for a while and
i looked in the market for four
different uh
solutions and i found this a
home based ai driven
farm it has a place for 30 plants
and it's a subscription model where you
get every month
uh pods with seeds and it has everything
there uh
irrigation lighting camera that
takes a picture of the plants and
basically it's done
there's an app and it turns on the
lights and tells you hey you need to
feel water
you need to clean this add some food so
and i've been using it now
yeah it's about four months wow and
we're eating every night from that
small farm it has a you know different
kinds of lettuces and uh
wow
one of the most important aspects of it
is it gives you a great virtual
background so you don't even have to do
it exactly
instead of putting a picture or a
virtual background which
my computer is too old and it doesn't
allow
i would have needed the green screen
behind me so this is the best
backdrop for me wonderful okay uli such
an impressive
background there's so much to talk about
from your time as an entrepreneur to
business development
you've held multiple ceo positions and
co-founder positions
but then you've handled numerous vp biz
dev and head of business positions so
i'd love to you know give me a little
bit of background about where you came
from and how you transitioned from
an entrepreneur and ceo to
a sort of you know the cbo or vp
business development
so basically my i'm an engineer
by training i went to 8200 in israel
to be in the military i've been there a
few years quite a few years
and i got out of there and basically
became an entrepreneur
started my first company it was a
technical technical startup
i was ceo founder ceo but also the
technology leader
and and they ran it for seven years
until it went to the ground
in in in the
2000 wow in the crash
seven years you worked on it yes
wow what was that like how hard was that
extremely hard there were like two or
three
so i had two acquisition opportunities
that
didn't happen one because of me because
uh because of hubris
and the second because of luck
you know i had a signed in mou
basically a signed agreement that got
rejected by
the board for some reason again
political stuff not related to me
um and two or three near-death
experiences throughout this year this
these years
and so it was a really rough
road but really interesting um
i think this this was my mba right
basically
i got down from my you know the pedestal
of the hubris
and i understood after a few years that
it takes a lot of work
and um and you know it's not you there's
no of course you have to work hard
but it's a lot of it's a lot about you
need to be in the right place in the
right time
and there is a huge element of
of luck in this road so basically
the way i see the world of technology
entrepreneurship
is that you may you place a bet on
something that will happen
in a few years it's not something that
is everything that is
is totally visible right now uh too late
for you as a as a
for starter you have to make a bet and
and this bet should be
large enough but on the other hand not
not in too large that everybody is
chasing it right now right
so we have basically just be something
outside and now the world can either go
that route or not go this route
and um and this is something that is
totally out of your control
so whatever you do you know you still
have to work hard
but you need to the world needs to go
your way in a way and at least
i would say 70 80 and you can pivot and
so on and so forth but
uh still you know in order to really
to to succeed something in the world has
to be
happening in your way right but then you
continue to be in the ceo positions from
for multiple other companies before you
train so so right
so i i of course you know basically i'm
an entrepreneur in my heart so even
even as a vp business i'm doing new
businesses right i'm working on new
opportunities
and so the the activity is very similar
it's basically creating new products and
new business opportunities and that are
open for
companies i think the main difference
for me
it was the fact that you're coming into
a more mature company
and and you so
just a little bit of less risk right and
but again i've been ceo before
and so in like five years ago i was ceo
four and a half years ago so it's not
i'm not ruling out
going back to doing that it's just a
matter of you know
it's opportunities what comes your way
and then you get
attached to something you you hop into
that
into the road right so
i've been after that i went to um after
my first company
i actually said okay now i'm i want to
join to be a ceo of a company not a
founder
and so i joined the company early stage
as ceo
and then i ran it for five years again
grew it from zero from
to millions of dollars again
and then at some point um it was sold
it wasn't huge success but it was sold
to an oem
and then i went to a another ceo of
another company
um in the vision in
the image for image analysis space was
ceo
i got an acquisition offer
that was finally rejected by the board
so i decided to move on
and then i got a call from tango so
basically it's all you know
you you you know in the high-tech space
again
because in the early stage it's a
high-stakes
a fast-moving market
and usually in three years you know
three four years you know
if this is going the right way or or you
understand you know where the world is
going you you don't plan for 20 years
but if if you plan your starter for 20
years from now you won't survive anyway
so it's something that should happen
like two three years if it doesn't
move in that direction you know i mean
you know we're saying two three years
but it doesn't sound like a lot but
it is a lot i mean it's a lot of days
you know we're talking about a thousand
days where you're basically you know
you're scrambling to find product market
fit to even realize
if this is something worth pursuing that
takes a lot of grit a lot of resilience
i agree and and and again it's at some
point
you realize what's going on in my last
ceo position
it was slip rate which was a sleep
improvement
uh service i need that consumer consumer
health
really interesting stuff there was a
huge issue
that consumers don't really want
to treat their health to their sleep you
know they all complain about it but they
don't really
treat it and especially you know they
can get a pill for a dollar
and they knock themselves out and it's
much better than go through a plan
that gives you you know more holistic
yeah
it doesn't matter so you know you f you
fight this fight and at some point you
realize that
you know does it work doesn't work and
you know
what are they you know what is the set
of dice
that you have in your hands to play and
of course and
um so
i think this is so for me against ceo is
in the early stages ceo is a product
manager and a sales guy
and an engineering manager basically
because you know
you have to make very drastic decisions
across a lot of things
and now you as the company move moves
forward and grows the ceo position
becomes more of an operational
right you know more finances more
organizational structure
more culturally all the time it's about
culture
but again early stage culture the
commando of every stage
has to transition as the company grows
into a more organized
structured and it's a different type of
of management style so as the companies
become more mature
you know for somebody who's an
entrepreneur in his heart if you join
this kind of a company
you need to be in a position that you
can create it's a it's very creative
very you know very dynamic environment
and that's what i'm looking for so um
that's
i don't know this is my road map you
know between you know
ceo and the and the dppd
very very similar roles actually
interesting i didn't realize that they
were so similar but but i have to say
that your passion for
for the two roles and their junction
just exudes through through the screen
so so i love it and i'm getting so much
inspiration from this
tell me a little bit about the different
vpbd
roles that you've held and and what what
sort of earned secrets have you gained
over these years both tango magisto
now move it incredible incredible
companies right
so i think that the um
companies who are consumer oriented
very very consumer-oriented have totally
different bd
um bd requirements
than companies that are b2b companies
and um
and also it's by definition bd
compared to consumer growth so if you
have
an arm of consumer growth that means you
know internet
playing with them with conversion
funnels and playing with the
growth hacking if this is the company's
growth
strategy then bt becomes a
who are the right partners to add to
that that will increase growth
or it's not revenue usually it's more
like
how do you grow faster how do we grow
right
because the end the end
the end goal is consumer
growth and and then
and and i noticed that in those
in those situations there is a very
strong
gap between the speed of bd
and the speed of growth okay
by definition is a slower process
you you the partners are usually large
because otherwise they cannot move the
needle right
so you look for partners that can move
the needle for you and
and they usually move slowly you know
you know verizon you know
samsung you know those kind of guys
there that
even though for them it's you know half
a half a year is quick
right now when you try to do business
development with these guys
and you have now to compare it to the
pivoting approach
of an early stage startup exactly early
stage startups
people do so by the time you finish a
deal
sometimes it's just totally irrelevant
because the company took a spin
to a different area so there is a race
condition between
the business development flow which is a
little bit slower
with big partners in the path of the of
the company so how do you manage that
dissonance because you're coming into
these companies as large as they may be
they're still
startups sort of right magisto you're
coming in and you're working on these
incredible
incredible ideas very creative but you
know very transformative with these huge
companies
and you know by the time that you get
this approved and you get everything off
the ground
the ceo tells you hey we actually are
doing something else
right so i think this is so it's
frustrating yeah
it's part of the role here in general i
look at bt for a startup
is a very disruptive process
because you know the product managers
are working on the
app again consumer facing right on the
working on the app they have a roadmap
you know features editing with features
building stuff like that
supporting the digital growth and
suddenly somebody comes with them say we
need to do a demo to samsung
okay so now you have to they need to
divert resources
they need and then when is it coming i
don't know maybe in six months and
actually i'm
going to give you 10 of those and one of
them would happen because nine you know
they don't happen
so basically it's a disruptive process
but it's
very important because you understand
how the market
so there is a significant
learning from those experiences because
you understand what they are looking for
how they see the market and it helps
the product team the engineering
management team of the companies
to really take a look and see okay this
is how the world look looks at this
problem yeah we are you know as a
startup we're really focused on
you know driving something that we
believe in in reality
not necessarily uh lives with it there's
a distortion by definition right there's
a
there's a distortion in the in the
vision right or the
chain is disruptive to the world and so
but you but you don't see the world
in many cases because you're so you know
closed
um view and
so i think so one of the roles is that
we did really brings in
perspectives that are not existent
otherwise totally and you know sometimes
it does help even though
you know so not every time there is a 90
people right or sometimes it's like a 10
people but then it helps i mean it's all
it grows it's it it helps the
maturation of the business so what would
you say are some of the top traits that
a good
vp of business development need to have
in order to be successful both at young
companies but also late stage
so i would say for again for technology
companies yeah i think there is there is
a need to have
it's a mix of
understand of technology understanding
you have to understand technology
because there's a
if you're not a technologist and you
come to do business it's
very hard because you need to close gaps
between what you
have in the technology and what they
look for
there is a so this gap is a technology
gap in some cases that you need to
understand
otherwise you just sell in you know
some you know some loofah something that
is not realistic
um so you have to have technology in
understanding if you
second is that you need to be uh to
understand business models
right and there is a there are so many i
mean the world
now is so complicated in terms of
different ways
to make money and to
get success so there is a so there is
that
part of the understanding so and the
last one is really
creativity and flexibility basically you
have to be a listener
right because you need to understand
what is the partner looking for
in what you have and this is something
that sometimes
is subtle sometimes they don't really
understand exactly
what it means so you have to make this
translation of what you have
to what they need and this is a it has a
lot of
usually it's very creative very um
you can listening you have to be
listening very very hard
to what problem they're trying to solve
right and then there is the
internal sales which is a huge challenge
as well
you have to sell not only to the partner
you have to come in and convince
the the the internal group whether you
know that it makes sense to actually go
after this opportunity
because again it's disruptive to the
normal flow of business
so it's a tough it's a tough position
but i think it's very dynamic very
people's oriented so
it combines technology and business
market and insights product you know so
there's
it's actually encompassing a lot of
discipline so
very fun right so so you know what one
of the key questions that i come across
when i think of business development is
looking at myself as a young
entrepreneur i'm going to start my own
venture
how do i know when i need to start you
know having
somebody else on the team that has this
you know entrepreneurial mindset
and and corporate understanding to know
when to do this business development so
at what point do i
do i say okay the company is now on a
certain mission and i need
this external factor or this x factor
within my company to go and think about
these new
new corporate developments i think that
the real
um so i would i would say two scenarios
one
you have um you've hit product market
fit
and now you're into growth right and
you're driving stuff
that that's a good time to make this uh
this addition right because then
you need to grow you need to you need to
have
partners to push you also understand
what kind of partners you're looking in
many cases
right as opposed to you know before that
you're just
running around to try to understand what
is the product that you're saying
um in some cases you know for
you know in some cases when you bring
somebody like that too early
and and could happen and then
then basically if you're very strong in
your vision
then it would be a disruption it
wouldn't work right and if you are
open and you say okay let's take this
kind of a talent
as one of the ways to test
the market to reach product market fit
if this is what you're
looking for then you know you can do it
really early um
but it really depends on how you were
basically what your preference is in
terms of
do you want to run the business you know
exactly what you want you know it's a
it's more of a ceo trait you know if the
ceo
says you know i know i have a vision i
know where i'm going you know don't
disrupt me don't
don't give me other you know don't give
it
too much noise i need to be focused at
that point
don't bring anything anybody else
because it will be disruptive it will be
annoying and noisy by definition
and the minute
it sounds complicated it sounds like
it's an art and that there's no right
answer
it sounds like you have it you know
every each to each his own
and and even once you employ a certain
strategy you don't know what the other
outcome would have been
but it takes a lot of understanding and
a lot of open-mindedness to go along
that route and definitely the one
takeaway that i'm taking from this is
this idea that
you know you have to find a balance at
the end about everything you have to be
focused on your mission you have to be
open-minded to different developments
because it's not just about your growth
but it's about the missed opportunities
that you might have in the market
if you're a disrupter in the market and
you have others that that are
you know that are around the same time
as you you know there's only
there's a there's a cake and you want a
good slice of that cake with the best
partners
so so uli thank you for all thank you
for all that inspiration i have one last
question because 20 minutes are almost
up
and i can't believe it every single time
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
i would say creative
um
honest yeah creative
honest in the
energetic i love it i it sounds like
that's pretty much what you need
to be a good vice president of business
development really
best of luck and move it it i mean i
love following everything that you're
doing it's so impressive
and so inspiring and thank you for your
time
thank you take care